il se passe quelque chose de grave est
bien avant l'été bétail à maigrir écoles
de compromis chaleur pour tout le monde
aucune des images que vous voyez ne
vient du sud ensoleillé ici c'est le
nord de la france on se trouve bien
devant une situation d'exception juin
1976 la france à chaud une canicule qui
n'était pas arrivé depuis 1947 soit 29
ans auparavant alors en 1976
les fortes températures faisait la une
des journaux télévisés
je pèse mes mots nous n'éviterons
peut-être pas cette année une véritable
catastrophe nationale
une catastrophe qui ne va pas attendre
29 ans pour se reproduire car c était au
dessus des normales saisonnières vont se
répéter encore et encore
l'exceptionnelle va devenir coutumier
l'autre jour les relevés de météo france
sont formels entre 1900 et 2000 très été
ont connu des températures au dessus des
normales saisonnières
très était en un siècle entre 2000 et
2010 8
c'est le même nombre très effet plus
chaud que la normale
non pas en un siècle donc les en
l'espace de 18 ans il était de tous les
records est encore aujourd'hui 2003 avec
trois degrés au dessus des normales
saisonnières et des pics de chaleur en
août et demain pas de baisse des
températures pratiquement le contraire
partout le thermomètre dépassera les 35
degrés on prévoit de 38 à 40 dans le sud
entre 41 et 43 même dans le sud-ouest
ces températures extrêmement élevées
pendant cet été 2003 ont causé la mort
de dix neuf mille quatre cent
quatre-vingt dix personnes en france
selon l'inserm le président de l'époque
jacques chirac s'était adressé aux
français à la fin du mois d'août
jacques chirac en première ligne après
la catastrophe sanitaire et sociale de
l'été le chef de l'état s'est adressé
aux français aujourd'hui aux milliers de
familles qui ont perdu un proche et au
personnel soignant qui l'a remercié
il demande également au gouvernement
mon de tout faire pour remédier aux
insuffisances révélées par cette crise
si les températures de 2003 n'ont pas
encore été égalée presque tous les étés
suivants ont été plus chaud que la
normale
et ça ne risque pas de changer pour
l'été 2010 9 météo france prévoit encore
une fois une saison plus chaude que la
normale
[Musique]